every summer solstice thousands of
people gather around the Stonehenge
monument in southern England to watch
the Sun Rise but there's a case to be
made that they're visiting six months
early I can't go to England right now to
show you why but we can do the next best
thing
[Applause]
[Music]
Stonehenge was built and modified
several times over the course of a
thousand years starting around 5000
years ago and this kit shows what the
final version probably looks like based
on the ruins that are there today but
some of these stones are simply missing
so archaeologists can't know for sure
that this plan was ever actually
completed these tall structures are
called trial Athens and the tallest one
is nine metres or around 30 feet there's
only three of them still standing today
but it would have been to accept that
they prop one back up in the 1950s
these smaller stones are called blue
stones the geological source for these
is over 200 kilometres away and there's
an ongoing debate about whether they
were carried to the site by people or by
glaciers sometime long ago even these
small stones weigh around three or four
tonnes so it would be like moving 40
dead hippos from DC to Philly without a
wheel this is a prehistoric project
which means that the Neolithic people
that built it didn't leave any written
records about why or how they were doing
this but they did leave behind some
clues like the antlers that they used as
pics to dig holes because antlers are
organic material they can be radiocarbon
dating which is how archaeologists can
estimate the chronology of all of this
these our stones weigh around 25 tonnes
and their source was more local but they
still had to be moved some 20 kilometers
and archaeologists can only guess at how
they did pad they're called sarsen
stones and they're harder than steel but
they were shaped into these fairly
uniform blocks using stone tools and
then they were pushed into pits before
being pulled up right
the stones in this top ring are called
lintels and you can't tell from this
model but they actually had joints like
woodworking joints there were grooves in
the lintels that fit into bumps on the
top of the upright stones and then on
the side of the lentils they also fit
together like puzzle pieces not only
that but the neolithic builders who made
this we're able to carefully calculate
the heights of all the stones so that
the monument was level even though it's
not on level ground it's truly an
engineering marvel
[Music]
grass tada except we're not actually
done the stone circle was just part of
the Stonehenge site it sits in a much
larger circle that was drawn in the
earth with ditches and mounds there was
an avenue leading up to the entrance of
that circle a big stone on that Avenue
called the heel stone and four other
stones that form a rectangle and may be
linked to certain moon cycles this site
must have been incredibly important to
the Neolithic people that built it but
despite hundreds of years of analysis
and speculation we'll never know for
sure what it really meant to them but we
do know that its design involved a
really early form of astronomy back in
the 18th century and historian noticed
that the central axis of the monument
points toward the location on the
horizon where the Sun rises on the
summer solstice so if you stood in the
center of the monument and looked toward
the heel stone you'd see the Sun rise
there on June 21st it's not a perfect
alignment but it's close
summer solstice is when the sun's path
is furthest north rising in the
Northeast and setting in the northwest
that makes it high in the sky in the
northern hemisphere and low in the
southern hemisphere this is all because
the earth is tilted relative to its
orbit around the Sun and the solstices
are where the sun's path appears to
pause and change direction but the
people that built Stonehenge didn't know
that the earth moves around the Sun or
spins on a tilted axis they probably
didn't even suspect it was round they
just saw the Sun bring longer days in
the summer and shorter days in the
winter and those turning points would
have meant a lot for their food security
and there's reason to think that the
winter solstice was particularly
important for the people at Stonehenge
the winter solstice sunset is on the
same axis as the summer solstice sunrise
just on the other end toward the
southwest and the midwinter
alignment shows up in other monuments
like the Newgrange tomb in Ireland which
has a window that allows the sunrise
to illuminate the inner chamber on the
sunrise of winter solstice archeologists
also found pig bones from a settlement
near Stonehenge that they believed were
slaughtered in the winter time based on
the pigs age their findings suggest an
annual winter solstice pilgrimage and
feast the idea is that people would have
approached the monument by walking on
the Avenue which would have put the
midwinter sunset in their sight line
right in the window of the tallest tryla
thon historian John North argued that
when viewed from this side the monument
silhouette would have looked like a
solid black form with the Setting Sun
bursting through bringing the promise of
another spring
[Music]